I'm John Wong from xor AI um thank you
for joining me today uh and I'm here to
talk about our open-source project
called X inference a platform that
simplifies the working with generative
AI um X inference provide a serving
feature for language embedding ranker in
image models and today we'll focus on
large language models
okay um so I'd like to start with an
introduction of large language models uh
or llms for short um these are complex
AI models designed to comprehend
generate um and interact with human
language uh the applications are vast
and diverse touching many aspects of of
Our Lives um I'm sure you guys are all
familiar with ch GPT which is one of the
most popular uh LM application in fact
uh I use the CH GPT to help prepare this
very speech script and it's very
useful um well CH GPT is great it has
some limitations for instance you cannot
use GPT to summarize sensitive documents
um and that's where open source models
come into
play so um let's talk about open source
large language models um there are a lot
of them open source models like Lama
offer several key advantages over closed
Source models like GPD 4 um they may not
be that powerful but forly they can Prov
provide better data privacy and security
um since you have control over the data
and infrastructure it's much easier to
ensure the sensitive information is
handled
securely um and secondly there's a
benefit of
customization um opsource llms can be uh
further fine tned to finish specific
needs and uh applications with your pro
uh private
data and thirdly they are cost efficient
um especially when compared to open AI
CPI you can save a lot from prompting
engineering and
experiments um so open source llms are
awesome but there are still
challenges uh for example choosing the
right model from a vast array of options
can be daunting and you also need to
figure out the correct prompt format
which is uh critical to interact with uh
within
llm and it could be different from model
to model um and serving efficiency is
another uh critical aspect as deploying
this models at scale can be resource
intensive um x in x inference is
designed to Simply simplify the
process okay uh now I'd like to
officially introduce X inference so the
platform is designed with each of use at
his core we offer a friendly a user
friendly interface and have simplified
the process to ensure that even those
who are new to AI can navigate and and
utilize our tools
effectively um one of the stand out
features of X inference is it's cross
Hardware
platform whether you are using gpus uh
from Nidia AMD or uh you are using apple
silicons or other accelerators X
inference is designed to work
similarly um X inference is also good at
performance and
scalability uh it's built to handle high
demand scenarios uh efficiently and
ensuring that your needs grow the
platform could scale with you uh and
maintain the performance without
compromise uh furthermore we have uh
integrated we have integrated with
popular third party libraries uh
including defy lanchan uh Lama index and
and others this integration can help
developers to um build an application
based on large language models uh much
more
faster so let's have a look at how to
use x inference um X inference provide a
flexible API it has its own python
client um but since openi CPI is a de
facto standard in the industry we also
provide an open AI compatible API so
that users can use x inference with open
AIS python client uh which is an
enhancement to user
experience um X inference also provide
web UI to simplify the management of AI
model models uh it's user friendly and
make and makes uh managing models
straightforward and efficient as you can
see you can um you can launch a SOA
model uh with a single click and you can
view the running models uh and you can
register a custom model with X
inference and once you uh choose a model
X inference well download the model and
launch a model instance for you you can
then chat with a model and or let a
model gener text uh on the web
UI uh or you can use a third party llm
Ops uh to do prompt engineering and
others uh okay so let's see how X
inference simplifies the creation of
prompts uh this is not about prompt
engineering this is uh about how to
interact with a model
correctly uh it's a critical part of
interacting with
llms so uh firstly The Prompt template
format users input to align with the
models training data this ensures that a
model interprets and responds to The
Prompt as expected uh it's a very
important step as a model uh the models
are sensitive to how inputs are
structured so uh for example a simple
user input like high there uh in X
inference it is not just passed directly
to the model uh it is extended to a
comprehensive prompt uh in the following
it includes a system prompt like you are
a helpful respectful and honest
assistant um and it also comes with the
special tokens uh in front of and uh in
the end of each
instruction uh and when you want an llm
to use external tools uh or invoke an
external functions like let's say uh a
search engine API you need to integrate
description of the tools into the system
prompt like how uh uh what does the API
uh looks like and uh what are the
parameters so for different models the
format of uh of the function call
description is different uh it's it's
kind of hard for users to learn about
everything about every model and X
inference handles uh this complexity
here
um okay so let's talk about the cross
platform
support um X inference is deployed uh
can be deployed on different Hardware
platforms including Nvidia uh and AMD
GPU uh and apple silicon and uh uh CPUs
um this is achieved by accommodating
various engines to S different models
and Hardware
setups so as you can see uh we have
supported uh VM tensor
llm uh for uh Nvidia platform uh they
are closely integrated with uh invidious
accelerators um and they can deliver
great throughput um and we also support
Transformers by hugging phase um it is
known for its extensive
compatibility uh and it supports almost
all the model architectures and they can
run on almost any
accelerator uh we also support uh GG ml
based engines like GMA CPP uh it is
optimized for Edge Computing uh in it
runs pretty well on CPUs uh and can
benefit uh and can also benefit from a
wide range of
accelerators so um as you can see there
are many of uh Hardware platforms uh and
sometimes it's hard for users to figure
out the right engine to use uh and X
inference will choose appropriate engine
intelligently according to your Hardware
platform
which greatly simplifies the model
deployment okay
um and let's talk about uh the GPU
memory uh memory management um so uh
everyone knows that uh GPU is is really
limited right now um so uh it is very
important to to use GPU memory
efficiently um during inference GPU
memory usage is actually
divided uh into three main parts uh the
model weights uh the activation and uh
the KV
cache so uh generally the KV cache is uh
it's a technology to accelerate
inference and this often occupies the
most GPU memory
um and generally the more the more GPU
memory allocated uh to K cach the higher
throughput you can
achieve um but it's hard for users to do
the maass and calculate uh like given a
desired throughput uh how much GPU
memory uh they should allocate to K cach
right uh and X inference helps in
determine the optimal amount of GPU
memory uh that for kav cach based on the
desired cput provided by
users um X inference also ensures that
uh there's no risk of running out of
memory during operations uh which
greatly improves uh stability uh the the
issue actually is that uh when the
sequence uh gets longer the amount of
GPU memory for K cach uh should be
should increases so uh if you are using
Transformers and without any like uh GPU
memory management um it's high uh it's
very likely that uh when you are working
with a long sequence uh there will be an
outofmemory error and uh you will not
get what you
want um so this careful management of
GPU memory is really helpful when
running multiple models on the same GPU
um for instance for an a rack
application you will need three models
uh one of them is an a large G Range
model and you also need an Bing model
and a ranker
model um so if you want to uh run the
three models on a single CPU you have to
figure out the GPU memory allocations so
that uh during the inference there won't
be uh there won't be an outof memory
error and um this is uh handles by
exence so uh I'd like to talk about the
performance and scalability of X
inference um X
inference uh also leverages parallel
decoding algorithms to achieve better
performance so the idea of parallel
decoding uh is instead of like the auto
regressive
algorithm uh which generate one token at
each iteration uh parallel decoding
algorithms tries try to generate
multiple tokens uh at it at each
iteration um speculative decoding is one
of the most uh popular parallel decoding
algorithms um
other other parallel decoding algorithms
including uh look head attention uh and
Medusa and the core of this uh
speculative decoding algorithm is to use
a smaller um quicker draft model to
several tokens in
advance um since the smaller model uh
since the weight of smaller model is uh
is much smaller and the amount of GPU
memory required for K cach is smaller uh
it can achieve better latency and better
throughput um so uh when you have
several tokens generated from the draft
model you can invoke the larger model to
validate the
result um this is done by
uh this is done by uh parallel
uh I mean uh you can you can actually
get a score of possibility of each token
uh at one
iteration uh of the larger
model and once uh you get a score you
can uh you can determine whether this
token is good or not uh if it is uh good
I mean it's it's higher than a certain
threshold you can accept a token and if
it's not you can discard the token and
the token follow uh the following
tokens uh so uh if the draft has a high
acceptance rate uh it can lead to a
great speeding
up uh the effess of this algorithm
depends on two factors the size
difference between the models uh the
larger the better and the similarity of
the logits produced by both
models uh using a 7 billion parameter
model as a draft model can speed up
inference in a 40 in a 34 billion
parameter Target Model by about
25% and impressively a draft model of uh
7 billion parameter can EX
accelerate uh 30 billion parameter model
by up to
100% um here's a demo of uh Lama 30
billion and as you can see uh on the
left side is a speculative decoding
instance and uh on the right side is a
regular instance and the uh speculative
one is much faster than the regular
one um and it's really simple to use
speculative decoding in XM reference uh
you just need to specify the draft and
Target Model uh and then you launch the
LM once setup the system treats it as a
regular model um handling the
complexities of speculative decoding
internally this means uh user can enjoy
the benefits of a f F model inference
without any uh additional complexity in
their
workflow and for the last part uh I'd
like to talk about the scalability of X
inference um so as the demand increases
X inference can scale out accordingly uh
in uring that Sero increases and latency
decreases in a linear fashion
maintaining performance and speed so to
illustrate this let's look at some
experimental data we conducted test
using Nidia RTX 1390 graphic cards uh
the results were quite remarkable uh
when we compare the performance on
single card to that on a dual card setup
this througho nearly doubled uh this
Improvement in througho is
significant uh as it demonstrates the
platform's ability to handle higher
volumes of data processing without
bottlenecks um equally important is a
reduction in latency the Dual card setup
decreased latency by about
80% comp compared to a single card this
reduction means that you can add more
resources to X inference the time taken
to process each unit of data decreases
substantially uh making the system
faster and more
responsive um okay uh thank you all for
your time and attention today